im mordfall buback bektas in berlin
neukölln
da steht ja 22 jährige mit vier freunden
vor einem wohnhaus es ist eine nacht im
april 2012 die jungen männer unterhalten
sich lachen trinken wodka energy als
plötzlich ein älterer mann auftaucht und
auf sie schießt zwei freunde werden
schwer verletzt bucher stirbt und der
täter ist bis heute unbekannt
der 22 jährige praktisch ein
sympathischer junger mann bei seinen
freunden ist er beliebt sie beschreiben
ihn als zuverlässig und immer gut
gelaunt
burak arbeitet in einem autohaus in
seiner freizeit macht er sport er wächst
als glückliches kind in berlin neukölln
auf seine familie ist türkischer
abstammung
er wohnt zu hause bei seinen eltern
zusammen mit seiner zehn jahre alten
schwester bis zum fünften april 2012
auf offener straße feiert ein
unbekannter mehrere schüsse auf buback
und seine freunde ab borat stirbt im
kugelhagel
ich werde die ganze nacht gab es schon
nicht vergessen habe ich auch nicht nach
zehn jahren
[Musik]
die sich an als ob es vor einer woche
haben die ganzen welt kann ich mich noch
sehr gut an der tod von burak hat das
glück einer familie zerstört
der fall bewegt mich sehr weil wir immer
noch nicht wissen wer der täter war
[Musik]
schaue die mutter anschaue in ihre augen
und ich fühle hier in schmerz und ich
kann das nach kurzem ein mann schießt
scheinbar wahllos auf eine gruppe junger
männer und flieht vom ersten tag an
berichten bild reporterin lena zander
und ihre kollegen über den fall buback
hektisch das ist das opfer von neukölln
um ein u 15 eröffnete der killer das
feuer diese verbrechen erschüttert die
menschen in deutschland bis heute
war es zufall war es ein rechtsextremes
akten tag warum musste burak bektas
werben obwohl die polizei mit hochdruck
ermittelt gibt es bis heute vom täter
keine heiße spur in gewisser weise das
perfekte verbrechen tat ohne
vorbeziehung
[Musik]
geht weg und verschwindet im gebüsch und
das war's bild reporterin lena sander
macht sich für achtung fahndung noch
einmal auf spurensuche an den schauplatz
des verbrechens dass eine ganze stadt
erschüttert hat sie trifft auf ermittler
und platz freunde die in der tatnacht
schwer verletzt wurden der tod von borat
beck das herz ich jetzt zum zehnten mal
noch immer gibt es keine heiße spur das
soll sich jetzt endlich ändern wer hat
in der nacht zum 15 april auf purer
bektas und seine freunde geschossen
es ist der fünfte april 2012 kurz nach
mitternacht hier an der rudower straße
in berlin neukölln ist der 22 jahre alte
bora queck touch mit freunden verabredet
reporterin lena sonder trifft sich genau
an diesem ort mit ömer und markus die in
der tatnacht mit dem rad unterwegs waren
wisst ihr noch an dem abend was er da
vorhatte das hatte der einen hand
geplant
wir wollten um die häuser bis ins 10
ja und dann haben wir
pro betroffenem erste und schon wieder
haben wir zufällig beim supermarkt
getroffen und dann dachten wir
verbringen gemeinsam die zeit dann sind
da hier auf der rudolfstraße bisher
umgelaufen armut und dicken wolken zum
nachbarn
[Musik]
fünf freunde burak markus aleksandrov
selten und ömer gehen an diesem abend
die rudower straße entlang zur
bushaltestelle ecke möwenweg dort halten
sie sich ein paar minuten auf
in dem moment passiert als es hier
passiert wird vom kreis haben uns
unterhalten ganz normal
ein bisschen die gruppe getrennte jeder
hat seine eigene sprecher
und ja dann habe ich gemerkt dass einer
kommt
und dann hat er einfach seine waffe
gezogen habe geschossen auf und mehrmals
dann hat er zuerst glich markus
getroffen
als ihr freund sondern schrie das ist
eine echte macht ist sind wir losgerannt
auf die straße dann habe ich gemerkt
dass
mitten auf der straße damit mich runter
zu ihm
war schon gut übersteht lag auf dem
boden war markus und alex lagen auf dem
bürgersteig und als ich mich zu den mann
gedreht habe statt doch da mit seiner
waffe gespielt
dann hat dass ich irgendwann umgedreht
davon wurde immer schneller
weißt du noch was in dem moment gedacht
oder gefühlt haft als borat auf der
straße lag gut überstand
der täter gibt mindestens vier schüsse
ab burak bleibt getroffen und
blutüberströmt auf der straße liegen
auch markus und alex werden
lebensgefährlich verletzt ich habe ihm
meinen bauch heim bekommen die es
durchgegangen und einer mainova die
steckengeblieben
genau da habe ich muss schreien noch
gehört ja und dann habe ich das erst mal
nicht realisiert da habe ich das blut
gesehen und dynamisches herz realisiert
dass eine waffe ist ich habe mal
geschrieben ich habe familie ich habe
familie sterben währenddessen kämpft
wenige meter weiter burak um sein leben
ich habe in seinen namen geschrieben und
dann habe ich irgendwann bemerkt dass
sehr viel blut auch nur das ging
wirklich sehr schnell außerdem und
überall war einfach gut burak bektas
erliegt noch in der nacht seinen
verletzungen er stirbt an den folgen
eines lungen schusses markus und alex
überleben sind aber schwer verwundet und
können nur durch notoperationen gerettet
werden
nach der tat flüchtete der täter
richtung möwenweg niemand hat ihn
seitdem mehr gesehen es war dunkel es
war kalt die straßen menschenleer
seine spur verliert sich
der tatort an der rudower straße 51
von hier aus flüchtet der täter richtung
norden welchen weg er hier genommen hat
ist unklar denn es gibt hierfür keine
zeugen
mir kam er ganz locker lässig vor kam
auf uns zu harmlos geschossen da kam mir
entspannt rüber also war ein spanisch
oder hektisch und den fall macht so
besonders dass man den täter eigentlich
gar nicht viel weiß der kam aus dem
nichts hat wahllos auf die gruppe junger
männer geschossen und letztendlich einen
von ihnen getötet
für die familie von burak bricht eine
welt zusammen
die schüsse haben das familienglück
zerstört
wir können es einfach nicht fassen wir
können uns das nicht erklären
bilder des glücklichen lebens dass der
killer zerstörte
im zimmer der trauer
das leid der familie hier ist wahnsinnig
groß man merkt auch die mutter das ist
eine gebrochene frau die hat ihren sohn
wie aus dem nichts verloren bis heute
kann sie auch nicht glauben dass ihr
budget nicht mehr wieder nach hause
kommen wird manchmal glaubt sie auch
noch seine rote kappen zu sehen und es
eher mit einer roten kappe wieder nach
hause kommt das kinderzimmer ist
unverändert man merkt das loslassen ist
wahnsinnig schwierig was auch daran
liegt dass der täter bis heute nicht
gefasst wurde niemand weder seine
familie noch seine freunde kann
verstehen warum buchert sterben musste
buback hatte keine feinde sagt immer im
gegenteil umschlug war meistens morgen
machen lustig
höchst bereits war immer für seine
freundin also
blieb der junge
hier auf dem muslimischen friedhof in
berlin neukölln wird burak bektas wenige
tage nach seiner ermordung beigesetzt
die anteilnahme für die familie beck das
war riesig mehr als 1000 menschen kamen
hier auf den muslimischen friedhof in
berlin um sich von burak zu
verabschieden an seinem grab spielten
sich herzzerreißende szenen ab
[Musik]
direkt nach der tat laufen die
ermittlungen nach dem täter auf
hochtouren eine hundertschaft der
polizei befragt anwohner im viertel geht
von haus zu haus die sechste
mordkommission rekonstruiert die tag
nacht und ermittelt in alle richtungen
doch zum täter gibt es keine heiße spur
vor allem die frage nach dem motiv
beschäftigt bis heute die ermittler in
einer pressekonferenz am ersten april
kurz vor dem zehnten todestag borax
wendet sich die berliner
staatsanwaltschaft noch einmal an die
öffentlichkeit
das problem bei diesem fall und bei
solchen fällen immer ist
das hier ebenfalls nach unseren
erkenntnissen eine vorbeziehung zwischen
täter und opfer nicht bestanden hat
jedenfalls haben wir dafür keinerlei
anhaltspunkte und
zusätzlich ein direkter kontakt zwischen
täter und opfer nicht
bestanden hat und dann hat man natürlich
relativ wenig objektive beweismittel
bisher ist über das motiv des täters
noch gar nicht viel bekannt man vermutet
eventuell einen rechtsextremen
hintergrund buback hatte türkische
wurzeln seine freunde haben
migrationshintergrund
und wenige schüsse dann gelten sollten
wenn der täter wirklich treffen wollte
auch das ist eine der fragen die bis
heute nicht beantwortet sind
wer hat burak getötet diese frage stellt
sich seine familie jeden tag
rechtsanwalt onur özer betreut seit dem
tod borax die familie beck dass
über den täter weiß man nicht sehr viel
wir wissen dass es ein mann gewesen sein
muss der über 50 war so beschreiben dass
alle
opfer und zeugen wir wissen dass er eine
eine kapuzenjacke an hatte und dass er
äusserst ruhig agiert hat also das war
jemand der sehr gezielt auf diese gruppe
zulief und die tat seite gezielt
ausgeführt hat wir wissen aber auch
nicht mehr er hat ja nicht mal was
gesagt als er geschossen hat drei jahre
lang kommt die ermittlungen nicht voran
doch dann gibt es einen weiteren
mordanschlag in berlin-neukölln nur drei
kilometer entfernt und der weist
parallelen zum fall buback hektisch auf
in der nacht zum 20 september 2015
fallen auch in der ringbahn straße
tödliche schüsse der engländer luke
holland wird auf offener straße nach
einem kneipenbesuch im berliner bezirk
neukölln ermordet sowie burak bektas
drei jahre zuvor als ketzer gerät
schnell läuft unter verdacht sein motiv
er fühlte sich durch den lärm auf der
straße gestört ermittler finden bei ihm
ein gewehr war er auch für den tod von
burak bektas verantwortlich der damals
ermittelnde staatsanwalt schließt das
aus
es gibt keine tragfähigen verbindung
zwischen den beiden taten die waffen
sind überprüft worden wir konnten
ausschließen dass die waffen von rolf z
die tatwaffen im fall buback baktasch
veranda steht fest
fz wurde im fall luca land zu elf jahren
und sieben monaten haft verurteilt im
fall murat bektas scheidet er für die
ermittler als dringend tatverdächtiger
aus
per live chat hat sich inzwischen mit
der polizei hat sich bei der polizei
geäußert er sei zeuge vernommen worden
war auch sehr aussage will ich ich kann
dazu den einzelheiten nichts sagen aber
ich kann soviel sagen dass das ein
tatverdacht gegen ihn in keiner weise
erhärtet hat die ermittlungen kommen im
fall buback bektas nicht weiter
dutzenden hinweisen wurde nachgegangen
hunderte menschen befragt die sechste
mordkommission ermittelt immer wieder in
dem fall kommt aber nicht zum durchbruch
der fall buback bektas wird zum cold
case
für die freunde von burak ist es
unerklärlich dass es immer noch keinen
fahndungserfolg gibt
traurig
man denkt immer wieder
in sehr guter freund also mein name in
der besten freunde und man ist traurig
und wütend dass der täter nicht gefasst
wurde er läuft herum er weiß wie wir
aussehen wie wissen nicht wie er
aussieht
da ist die einzigste sache die
beängstigend dass er kann neben mir an
der kasse stehen unter stress test
affäre
um den fall im gedächtnis der
öffentlichkeit aufrecht zu erhalten
wurde eine initiative gegründet die
durch kundgebungen und mahnwachen immer
wieder an den tod von burak bektas
erinnert vom sechsten todestag von burak
bektas 2018 wurde das denkmal hier
hinter mir eingeweiht
25.000 euro hat es gekostet
es wurde finanziert zum teil auch durch
spenden durch die initiative zur
aufklärung des mordes an buback bektas
immer wieder bei dieses denkmal
rassistischen anfeindungen ausgesetzt
so auch im letzten jahr altes mit einem
hakenkreuz beschmiert wurde jetzt
pünktlich zum zehnten todestag von burak
soll das denkmal wieder im glanz gesetzt
werden der platz hinter mir wird neu
gepflastert damit die menschen hier
zusammenkommen können um das zu gedenken
am fünften april 2012 schießt einmal in
berlin neukölln auf eine gruppe junger
männer der 22-jährige burak bektas wird
dabei getötet zwei seiner freunde schwer
verletzt die ermittler beschäftigen
folgende fragen wer hat am fünften april
2012 gegen 1 uhr 15 in der rudower
straße in berlin neukölln
auffälligkeiten bemerkt gesucht wird ein
männlicher täter er trug dunkle kleidung
und einen kapuzenpulli es handelt sich
um einen mittelalterlichen etwa er etwas
älteren täter soll es sich gehandelt
haben nach angaben der der
geschädigten es wurde eine bestimmte
kleidung beschrieben
außerdem wer kann angaben über den
fluchtweg machen oder hat andere
verdächtige beobachtungen gemacht die
ermittler von damals und die bild
redaktion
sie alle möchten dass dieser brutale
mord endlich aufgeklärt wird mit ihrer
hilfe da draußen lässt immer noch jemand
herum der ein menschenleben auf dem
gewissen hat dieser täter muss halt
endlich dingfest gemacht werden
das wünschen sich auch borats freunde
markus und auch wenn ihnen das ihren
freund nicht zurückbringt glaubt man
kann nie damit abschließen das ist ja
das verfolgt mich jedes mal auch wenn
der täter gefangen wird
und dann dann ist einem gefängnis hat er
trotzdem die tat begangen
immer wenn ich die mutter sehen oder
wenn ich zu den nach hause gehe denkmal
noch mal wieder anging und man ist
traurig und die mutter wird ja auch
immer wieder traurig wenn sie und sieht
sie fängt immer wieder an zu weinen und
das ist ja normal sie hat ihren sohn
verloren und der täter wohl immer noch
nicht gefasst
wer hat burak bektas getötet einen
jungen mann der mit seinen freunden
einfach nur einen schönen abend
verbringen wollte jeder hinweis jede
zeugenaussage kann zur aufklärung dieses
verbrechens beitragen
helfen sie den fall buback bektas
endlich zu lösen
hinweise an die polizei berlin unter der
nummer 030 4664
[Musik]